hello and welcome to this video playing
speckled band
with black
okay it's got a good number of games
played
playing the smith mora
and i declined it just it's it's often
reasonable
just for blitz game people play this
myth more
rarely play the white side of a muroxy
point
in um in a good way
it's just um
a general observation over the years but
we'll see what happens
this definitely is okay for white what
he played
so bishop e6
i'd like to trade a little bit here
got less space and trades are welcome
so rook c8
not sure about this and this is usually
helpful
cover e7
i have four minor pieces this is a
little bit too much
in this position
i'd like to have some traded
yeah white is definitely a bit better
okay this is not
usually that dangerous but we'll see him
trading this bishop as mentioned i don't
mind trades
now 95 that would be nice for me but
don't think he's going for that i think
he wants to
rather play for an attack
maybe queen b2 or something like that
okay um
maybe get the knight over to them to the
king side
i'm also preventing h5
and this is an interesting moment
because
i'm not sure that this is actually a
threat i don't think it is so
i'm going to allow the capture
this is i think improving my pawn
structure a little bit
he's he should not be able to attack the
pawn on e6
and with the pawn on e6 at least 95 is
never an option
yeah that looks pretty okay interesting
why isn't h6 just okay
let's do that
i also have the idea to play queen h5
and then maybe g5
um okay let me know then then maybe
bishop b2 then right
that that actually does make some sense
g5
is definitely a move
and then use the e5 square
now queen e5 that is a beautiful square
for the queen
i cannot take on g3m because f6 is a
check
but now yeah i was
seriously threatening this um
are we going to checkmate him on the h
file
almost okay so
the other idea here is to prepare b5
actually
maybe i should have gone gone for that
anyway threatening b5
now
the move a4 would stop that
in its tracks but
that gives me plenty of dark square
play okay so b5
now knight b6 i have rook b8
so b5 he goes to b2 right
that is his idea and now
i could go b4 but he is not
actually i think i should do that
actually
play b4
and this can also come to c5 all right
so
he's preparing f4 but f4 is still
e4 hanging okay so
knight e4
knight e3 okay um
sorry king e3
knight c3 doesn't work
try to fix all these pawns on light
squares maybe i had something
um more substantial
like something tactical but i did not
see it like
winning a pawn that would have been of
course
um even nicer but i did not
see it couldn't make it work
okay not a move that i expected but
it's interesting yeah i have to take
that
that's a bit of a that's a bit of a
letdown
that this is necessary
ah that is really not good
i was totally planning on exploiting the
the um the bad bishop
well this is nothing and and just just
equal rook f1 okay
rook f1 i thought was a bit better
you know it's still it's still equal
rook f1 rook cf1
no it's still equal
i i will i will try but it's just um
objectively it's it's nothing
okay wow why
that was not necessary
yeah somehow i ground him down him in
this position
but that was not not necessary at all
i think um there are some interest
instructive moments i think
when we start here i don't think bishop
g5
is all that appointed
the the bishop trade i don't mind but
white is not worse by any means but i
wouldn't
really play bishop h6 myself so it takes
takes
and the engine suggests queen b2 this is
indeed a very good idea
and something that i also feared during
the game
because it threatens all these
discovered um
checks and i have to lose um
a tempo due to that like f6 or king j8
and then
after a knight d5 let's say we let's
play that
and then there is this before idea and
it's really uncomfortable so
this is also why maybe the bishop
exchange
is not so bad if he follows it up with
queen b2
the way it happened i was not really
that concerned
a bishop g4 is also a very valid move
the bishop is notoriously useless in
such a position
and would be happy to trade him
very true 97 is not a mistake
but i think what he should not do is
what he did going for this exchange it
really does not help
like in in this position
i'm just starting to be in very good
shape
maybe i should play it actually without
a queen trade
but i mean i'm happy with this this
position is just good
yeah this is just a good position i can
probably improve
in in some way knight h5 to f4 is
interesting but okay i'm
kind of wondering
if there was something here
oh knight b6 is a move
wow
he has this sacrifice interesting
yeah it seems that i cannot
take him because this is a bit too fast
yeah okay not
not nice so that was interesting
and here okay the computer wants to take
on c4
ah that makes a lot of sense i did not
and so i didn't understand that the
problem is
he cannot take because of d5 and then
winning material
that is that is a huge point
if he has to take with a pawn that's
obviously something that i should do
isolate his pawn and then i have
excellent squares and plenty of
pawns to attack i know that my pawn
structure
also looks a little bit um yeah a little
bit shaky but
he can actually not attack them at all
how does he attack those does it work
yeah b4 in comparison is of course much
worse
and now we played this this weird f4 i
mean
weird um yeah it's surprising but
it seems to work yeah i don't i'm not
able to
exploit exploited in any way and here
he seems to be fine bishop h5 is a
is an interesting solution just forcing
off this bishop and it seems like the
engine
doesn't want to play that move but it
looks fine
i mean i cannot move the king this is
certainly
um maybe this would blunt an exchange
but like this this doesn't look right
yeah
to move into all those checks so i have
to take it
and this is probably just equal and here
rook f1
i thought would be better but maybe i'm
wrong
okay
yeah it's equal i mean here you can take
yeah and
forced me to take with the pawn for
equality still this
this should not lose of course but he
completely
um lost the plot here
this is i guess still okay and now
yeah think take yeah c5 i don't know
c5 must be based on some some weird
um yeah miscalculation
i don't know didn't he had 14 seconds so
so i just take and um yeah here
it's getting getting really bad
so i was a bit surprised still by the
resignation but the position is very bad
after king d7 uh possibly there's also
made threat yeah just to show
um i'm not sure that this is the best
move by the way
but like he has e5 but i'm threatening
mate here with e5
but um he can play this himself and this
definitely increases um
chances for survival i will probably go
rook c5 here again
maybe this is also not bad
like slowly improving that that's the
thing probably it should win but
it's still some work okay guys thanks
for watching